there's something like someone moving
something outside hello my followers
just a quick heads-up you're all going
to die and it is 100 to give you a look
at the end is that the wick I just had
on it's the evil wig
it also means it's time for lunch so
let's go get lunch
ah that's great man Jim you really make
me want to just step up my game now
hilarious exactly
so I can say that ass badass that ass
that ass is going to win he has a choice
he can either let everyone die or he can
go say Trinity who's they pretty much
establish is gonna die anyway so he goes
after her no no no that's right it was a
Matrix Reloaded definitely is yeah we
was no no no you see like yeah it's like
a really big shock The Matrix movies are
kind of perverted yeah no but there's
this scene where it's like yeah there's
like this whole log you marry this long
like almost orgy of like it's it's like
a religious orgy to of like everyone
dancing and stuff and then neo and
Trinity like just making out there's no
story no plot no anything it's just
please ruinous like soft porn oh vaguely
yeah yeah yeah no I it's like everyone
watching us like - this is like five
minutes movie what are you doing yes
like everyone's just having sex and yeah
total character speech it's like utility
is it totally different character
I fear the tonight we dine in
Independence Day here's something every
big cliche
yeah I guess I was them trying to show
yeah they're still human and Oh Tamra
are you taking a catnap this is probably
we're shooting the second review even
though the first review isn't that Foley
shot yet I got six I couldn't shoot my
stuff you know the stuff with me like
talking to you know smoke and stuff like
that so I'm gonna try and shoot that
after we shoot everything else today if
not I'm just gonna push it to tomorrow
I'm feeling yeah your voice sounds baby
it sounds a lot better yeah it's weird
it goes in and out like sometimes it'll
be like really clear like right now in
the dark times it's really hot so I'm
just trying to Dalek all the t's and
liquids and flush it all out yeah why
not yeah
it's so weird cuz sometimes I feel great
and there are times I'll feel terrible
and sometimes we'll have a ton of energy
sometimes I'll just want to sleep like
whatever two o'clock another day or
something like that so oh yeah really
weird but as much differs from your
normal life n'yar pretend the our deeds
are like me and go get a flu shot
oh no
Chester did you want us to any we're
just gonna go Zoop did you want us to
bring rest well we're back
Oh kind of Tamra's been as Tammy
oh the Tammy because it's already its
puzzle the green oh yeah that's right
everything had a weird green tint yes
when green ruled the world
Oh girls method actors now you are tama
D it's not all you guys are like
completely different characters just
like see you in those clothes yeah I
want
this code ready my gun or no oh yeah
your big gun yeah grab it daddy grab a
gun out there thank you big guns now
alright so I'm I did I'm gonna be right
here pretty much you know turning
talking to you guys these are your lines
we'll do a run-through Yeah right we do
this they did if you want to just so
very even look again thanks boy yeah uh
what are you still doing here what I
mean it's like I feel like we completed
the story with you guys so what are you
still doing here
oh no there's much much more that can be
done with us I don't think so it was a
beginning middle and totally serviceable
anything else would just be filler no
clearly we were just telling part one of
our story part one yes just like all the
other obviously planned trilogies like
highlighter transformers and of course
to the Caribbean plus one but those were
all just supposed to be one film until
the studio came in and forced them to
make a trilogy but American this
recording is blinking on all of that
supposed to happen
yep alright yeah so so yes I guess I
just sort of like you know like it's
trying to yeah well I like that that's
good light like a tiny bigger you like
it
you can even grab your hands and help
yourself and push it oh yeah that just
happened
get out of here this one's gonna have
enough filler as it is these lines I'm
cutting you know it's a bad idea to tell
a creek he's the Messiah
why that's two most critics things here
anyway put up um stated to maybe it was
a bad idea and you had like as you're
saying that you're mostly going to be in
the corner and so you're sort of saying
that as you're walking out pretty much
okay we're talking to you you're low
ground
I'm in your debt yeah okay how did you
go around let's have you before the room
so this is one line that I think you
have so what you have to get down
because I actually okay
lies in the truth of the lie and then I
so the way it's gonna happen is that I'm
gonna be here you we're gonna have a
agent schmuck is right in front of me a
bunch of agent remarks and I'm like you
know and he's boring me to death by all
these talks of you know pretentious
speeches is so something you know oh oh
oh and you're and it's gonna be a medium
shot and then what I'll probably do I go
you know oh and then I'll go now and
when I say now that's when you to come
in on either side and Jim you back up to
sort of reveal them as well and
Malcolm's gonna be saying a bunch of
pretty yeah a bunch of pretentious
mumbo-jumbo and what we'll do is and I
say after we get to the point where you
say in the truth of the lie like after
you say that after he says the truth of
like go ahead have the camera it's it's
always gonna be a little moving you know
a little look going around after he
entry says lies in the truth of a lie
get a close-up of the two of us I'm
gonna say well what's going on Terry you
see it's pretentious blow-off
they're seeing
make the most nonsense salad for critics
yeah it's very straightforward
it's a pretentious blow-off yeah there
you go
and then Malcolm yeah you you keep yeah
and so after that you mostly go back you
mostly keeping up Malcolm you sir keep
going in and out of the jangles and so
on so forth like he's mostly just gonna
be talking nonsense and pretentiousness
and stuff like that oh you guys come in
our destiny is not one that can be
changed unless its meaning lies and the
truth of the of the lie is what's going
on yeah they're trying to see they're
trying to spit out nonsense and see what
you can make that's all figured out if
only to don't say it's a pretentious
blowjob and they're gonna sweat out what
he sort of ACTA like you know you can
serve bumble to yourself but like it
doesn't have to be so yeah so be sure to
keep on us so here we'll just do another
run from here so our Disney is not one
day be foretold unless its truth lies in
the meaning of the lie well we'll wait
now what's he doing
it's a pretentious hospital they're
trying to see who can spout the most
nonsense and make sense of it okay
our past can't be changed for it is the
duty of our first in the duty of tittie
it is a duty of past to control the
future to control our present oh my god
he blew their ears off okay so what
Malcolm Malcolm do you remember I showed
you to put the sword in yeah you get you
get your hand closer to the top so you
can guide the point right yeah yep
well actually you actually your hand
goes none of your hand goes even higher
than the you know and then yeah and then
that's right and then your hand guides
it in yes and then once you're sure it's
again then then jam it in okay let's do
one more
yeah our destiny is not one that can be
for total as its truth lies in the
meaning of the purpose of the lie well
what's he doing it's a pretentious
blow-off they're seeing who can make the
most nonsense sound important our
destiny cannot be changed our paths
cannot be changed
I was gonna say is it possible just to
make it up are you gonna making up that
stuff at all I'm not really um do you
get the basic gist yeah yeah I can get
the basic his path and duty
okay our destiny cannot be foretold for
it unless it's truth okay guys ready our
destiny isn't that one that can be
portals that's truth lies and the
purpose of the lie what's he doing
they're having a pretentious blow-off
seeing who could spout enough nonsense
and make sense into it okay and our
distance are not one that can be
foretold for us the truth that lies in
the purpose of the lie okay I'll try it
one more from the beginning yeah okay
and our destiny is not one that can be
foretold unless it's truth lies and the
purpose of the lie well what's going on
here
it's
ten just blow off their seeing who can
make the most nonsense make sense let's
say from what's going on here okay ready
and action
what's going on here it's a pretentious
blow-off they're seeing who can make the
most nonsense make sense
our paths can't be changed for is them
for it is say you can take a friend of
the path cannot be changing take it from
there yeah our paths where is the duty
of the past to control okay our paths
cannot be changed for is the duty of the
past to control the future to control
the present to deny who we are to deny
what we are to deny why we are that my
friend is life itself
boom oh my god you literally blew their
ears off don't ever do that my
pretentiousness again good action our
source of our sources have indicated
that the pathway to knowledge is here
but what plot line filler to direct
things out oh well all right you guys go
find that and I'll just continue doing
the review okay I am madly in love with
you where the hell did that come from
come on tell me that's like the fifth
Messiah you tried to have the hots for
what would it be easier if Malcolm walk
behind you Doug oh yeah cuz then yeah
we're gonna no way you can still see the
reaction yeah okay that's it do you guys
still need the line so you think again
yeah okay so yeah so you just got done
putting okay Jim ready to shoot rollin
all right and action our sources have
indicated that the pathway to knowledge
is here what filler plotline to direct
things out
oh right well you guys go find that and
I'm just gonna keep doing the reveal
okay I am madly in love with you I come
from I'm number five and action our
source of okay all right guys I'm and
action our sources have indicated that
the pathway to knowledge is here what
filler plotline to drag things out oh
all right well you guys go find that
filler plotline while I continue with
the review okay I mentally love you
where the hell did I come from I'm
number five okay uh well one more I want
to know more okay ready and action
our sources have indicated that the
power to knowledge thing is right and
path away
pathway of knowledge and action our
sources have indicated that the pathway
of knowledge is here what filler
plotline to drag things out oh yeah all
right well you guys go look for that
plot line thingy and I'll just stay here
continue the review okay I am madly in
love with you where the hell did that
come from
I'm number five Doug when she says I'm
in love with you your line comes so fast
could you do a reaction I'm in love with
you where the hell did that come from I
kind of like this penis you do okay just
like well the head movement is good okay
like that okay and action our sources
have indicated that the pathway to
knowledge is here what filler plotline
to direct things out
oh all right well you guys continue on
your little side quests I'm just gonna
keep doing the review all right I am
madly in love with you where the fuck
did that come from
come on Tammy that's like the fifth
Messiah he had the hots for I'm number
five I see that okay so our entry says
too late for that okay
yeah too late for that too late for that
pretty much it's in the kitchen we'll
take the outside agents won't suspect us
too late for that oh we should pray put
the focus to light for that
too late for that
you'll be Jewish by time this is over
cameras too light for that okay so what
happens if monk closes the door and then
we're gonna get to this side you got
here camera come here let's see probably
yeah probably Tamra open you're good to
work and we stay inside we're looking
and we're seeing nothing but mountains
up there cuz that's what they can do the
matrix I can make it where you something
in the mountains and how can you say oh
no you put us in the mouth
all right so I'll give you the
background we re so in the movie there's
this one of the things they can do is
they can put a key in a door and they
can open up whatever in China or
something like that you'll still be here
but you can open up inside that you want
to do it at any point you have to have
the key I think so right yeah the key
master does it yeah yeah yeah so but
like here's the thing so you got neo
there he's going after the bad guy bad
guy closes the door and everyone else is
going to have in those highway chase
like it upstairs on the highway and
stuff so he goes chases this guy kicks
open the door and he's in the mountains
and he's like dude Who am I you're in
the mountains alright so he was halfway
around the world back to the highway
where he saves the good guys in time but
I bring up why the hell doesn't he just
turn around because they it's still the
same room there why doesn't he just turn
around and walk upstairs where the
highway is yeah so pretty much so in
this scene is oh no we're in the
mountains and both of you like pretty
much like grabbed my arm like you know
like sir put it like oh wow would you
guys like you know like you know you're
like yeah like you know you're gonna fly
with us you're gonna mow he literally
flies yeah you ate a meal oh no he was
in the mountains and immediately you
guys start putting like my arms around
you guys yo and welcome you say oh
alright critic you need to fly halfway
around the world in order to get us back
and yeah you guys are just like yeah
you're just like oh now say like you did
before I love it oh no
yes I hear you guys just look over the
actions all that stuff oh no you put us
in the mountains hi say uh well when you
do that go ahead sort of be like maybe
right there no yeah I I feel ok so if we
start off here it's probably good yeah
yeah and yeah you probably push open
even faster - no you put us in the
mountains yeah like as you're getting
the arms together go ahead and start
saying oh it's alright and action
oh no you put us in the mountains all
right Chris class halfway around the
world in order to get ready Jim and
action oh no you put us in the mountains
alright critic we need you to fly us
halfway around the world in order to get
us back or I say we could just use the
other way to the kitchen through the
office yeah that's not what I like that
even better
oh uh oh no all I wrote that I do right
this wrong okay no no there be Mountains
in with his thumb that's great yeah yes
I know there's mountains out there but
there's nothing but office in here
that's like yes I know there's mountains
out there but there's still office in
here it's like your idiot Messiah and
then we'll
okay just say goodbye cool just use
these to the kitchen to seize the oh we
could just use the other way to the
kitchen through the office but there yes
I know there be mountains out there but
they still office in here it's like our
India Messiah I say you can even hold it
a little longer after I say you know
through the office and action we could
just use the other way to the kitchen
through the office but there be
mountains yeah I knew there be mounting
this fight in here there still office
it's like our idiot Messiah good good
okay I say you can even a little bit a
little longer we could just use the
other way to the kitchen through the
office but there the amount yes I know
there'd be mountains out there but
they're still office in here it's like
our idiot Messiah good one more chances
we could just use another way to the
kitchen through the office but yes I
know if it be mountains out there but
they're still office in here it's like a
idiot Messiah good
I only just read this line real fast
hey quit on set he flies thousands of
miles around the globe to reach our
heroes but all he has to do is turn the
fuck around and go back the way he came
he never closed the door so it's the
same location behind him it would have
taken him two minutes
Charl more he flies thousands of miles
around the globe to reach our heroes but
all he had to do was turn the fuck
around and go back the way he came he
never closed the door behind them so
it's the exact same location I'm gonna
take it in two minutes okay good good
all right and this one this I can't
you're just very slow as money together
Oh
so instead of flying around the world
why don't we take a few steps w K yeah
okay if at all even so I'll say you
won't take it in two minutes and we're
taking it two minutes ah so instead of
flying around the world we can just take
a few steps back to the kitchen yeah
let's do it let's do a few steps back to
the kitchen okay well when you exit go
ahead exit this was that walk yeah yeah
yeah towards that camera and I say leave
a really long pause before to the
kitchen to the kitchen because then I'll
praise talking for a moment to the
kitchen to the kitchen okay I'll start
with it where are we looking at sorry um
okay um all right so I'll start with it
we'll take it what just taking two
minutes
hey guys ready and action
I'll take it two minutes ah
so instead of flying around the world we
can just take a few steps yes behind
this door are the answers to all the
pictures movies all the answers like why
they're so silly and make no sense
every single one let's check out and
we're all just pretty much action this
is the pathway of knowledge yes behind
this door are all the answers to all of
the Matrix movies all the answers like
why they're so silly and make no sense
every single one of them let's check it
out good
okay China yeah a little bit more bad
yes okay to knowledge okay okay action
this is the pathway to knowledge yes
behind this door are the answers to all
of the Matrix movies all the answers
like why they're so silly it makes no
sense every single one of them let's
check it out good go do that while I
finish up the review it's a why I'm
saying page of the review those things
yeah yeah bad menu to just I think yeah
just walk off that way yeah no well walk
off and then like tea leaves is doing
okay so so one more time so we come in
the frame that didn't seem right there
must have been a connection issue we
have to destroy the power source there
all right all right side mission you
guys go do that while I finish up the
action what didn't seem right there
must've that didn't seem right there
must have been a connection issue we
must destroy the power source
- yeah yeah yeah another side mission go
do that while I finish up the review
stop that
and action
that didn't seem right there must have
been a connection issue you must destroy
the power source yes yes yes another
side mission that I guess if the nights
we action that didn't seem right there
must have been a connection issue we
must destroy the power source dig
another citation you guys go do that
while I finish up the review stop yeah I
never do know you've seen the word side
mission so fast it's a little hard under
okay that didn't seem right there must
have been a connection issue we must
destroy the power source take again our
side mission you guys go do that while I
finish up the review stop I want a
parent you're gonna make me day as you
can see we're nearing the end of the
shoots and everybody's ready to give him
let's get say it's not merely begin for
me but today yeah I think it is yeah I
was saying I was either gonna fill my
stuff right afterwards or like the few
days after I can't if you'd accept your
sound good okay we need the bugs so is
this gonna be like a week behind I think
that's what we're gonna do is that we're
still gonna shoot I think we're still
gonna shoot the last one on the same day
two weeks from today you know what we'll
just have everything kind of shot I know
in a question if this turns out which
then we do not shoot the gameshow next -
really
that opens up that Tuesday did you want
to shoot then in case the gameshow goes
to two weeks I can check I'm going out
of town the 20 seconds and I'm gonna be
gone until the 2nd of February okay so I
planned it out to just be here for the
next shoot and then the one after though
can we fill in Tuesday's I will not be
here Tuesday's I'm sorry
I won't be here the 20